hello I'm Greg sampler the president of
reason I oh and I'm very excited to tell
you about a new partnership we're
embarking upon with the company out of
school out of school specializes in
providing a platform that can connect up
to different kinds of people one is
expert content providers like myself in
my case in philosophy and a few other
fields and on the other side our
homeschooling parents and children and
perhaps other parents and children who
have their children enrolled at other
schools but would like to beef up their
educational content I'm a big fan not
only about school's mission but also
their platform which is quite elegant
and easy to use I think that it's a
great thing to be able to offer high
quality content from expert providers to
children especially since we we don't
generally have much philosophy in our K
through 12 curriculum so I think it's a
laughs on the part of our educational
institutions and I applaud these these
platforms like out school that are doing
a great work in bringing these
possibilities to those who want to take
advantage of them so if you have young
inquiring interested mine's at home that
are looking for some high quality
engaging content from expert providers
especially in philosophy that that's an
area that we don't get enough of in our
K through 12 curriculum here in the
states then check out out school i
highly recommend it as a parent and i'm
going to be one of the providers right
now i'm in the process of building a
number of courses for out of school some
of them are going to be 8 to 16 week
course is quite structured in classic
philosophy i'll also be offering a lot
of seven
if you want to just get your feet wet
these are completely free you can sign
your you're interested learner up today
and they'll get to you know check out
Plato Aristotle the Stoics Augustine all
sorts of great classic text thinkers and
topics in philosophy so to sum up well
we've got he ran out of school in a
really excellent platform that I think
is going to be doing some wonderful work
in helping parents and students find the
people who are interested in working
with them to develop high quality
content check it out today and see what
you think